Violent chaos unfolds across the shoreline.
Huge fleshy tendrils slither out of the water,
grabbing people who try to flee and dragging
them into the depths, as giant harpoons made
of bone whizz across the beach, cutting down
unfortunate sunbathers in droves.
It’s a terrifying massacre, but you’d
never in a million years be able to guess
its source…
On April 10, 2010, something strange began
to happen in the Three Portlands.
Now, the anomalous, extradimensional city-state
that overlaps with the locations of Portland,
Oregon, Portland, Maine, and the Isle of Portland
is no stranger to unusual occurrences, so
it took the population a little while to notice
that something was happening.
But, for some unknown reason, sailboats and
motorboats were beginning to vanish from the
city.
The disappearances occurred overnight, when
there was no one around to witness them, but
slowly the citizens began to notice that their
friends and family members were going out
in their watercrafts, and never returning
home.
By April 15, the civilians were becoming noticeably
concerned, fearing the worst.
On April 16, their worst fears were confirmed
when two local ghosts, Onkar Ahmad and Greg
Moore, went for a nighttime stroll along the
Harbor.
They heard a sudden commotion, and rushed
to the scene of the disturbance.
They arrived just in time to see a living
individual being dragged into the watery depths
by a large, vein-like tendril.
Ahmad asked Greg to wait on land, while he
ventured out into the water to look for the
victim.
Unfortunately, Ahmad never came back, and
Greg took his story to the Three Portlands
Police Department.
After waiting a few days for the local man-eating
clam population to migrate, the FBI Unusual
Incidents Unit mounted a formal investigation.
On the morning of April 17th, all of the missing
vehicles suddenly reappeared.
This left the UIU, and the people of the city,
with even more questions.
Where had the boats all gone?
Why were they suddenly back?
And what had happened to the missing people,
who had not been returned along with them?
On April 19th, UIU agents dove into the harbor
to search for any unusual activity, and while
they didn't spot anything especially strange,
they did discover that there were fewer animals
in the harbor than usual.
On April 21, the threat that had been preying
on the citizens of Three-Portlands actually
made itself known.
At 11:19 AM, 17 boats moved away from the
docks on their own, drifting up onto shore
though no one could be seen captaining any
of them.
As the boats lined up, they began to form
a wall blocking access to the water.
No one could get in, or out.
Civilians watched in shock as the boats began
to warp and change before their eyes, growing
thick masses of scales on their surfaces,
sprouting harpoon guns that fired boney projectiles,
and slashing veiny tendrils at anyone within
reach.
The citizens began to panic, running in every
direction in an attempt to escape the monstrous
boats.
But they were too slow to evade the attacks,
and the boats snatched them off of the shore
and yanked them aboard, using their harpoons
to impale those who managed to run further
than the tendrils could stretch.
As the army of fleshy boats closed in around
the shore, a tugboat broke the surface of
the water.
Unlike the rest of the boats, it had a noticeable
hole in its hull, and was missing its wheelhouse.
At an unnaturally quick pace, the tugboat
began to advance onto land, using its tendrils
to drag itself along the shore and into the
more populous part of town.
It grabbed civilians at random, absorbing
their blood into its metallic surface as it
went.
Suddenly, it spotted Albert Izatt, a noted
member of the Church of the Broken God, and
began to focus its attack on him.
But before the tugboat monster could reach
Izatt, a city security golem interfered.
Sadly, though the golem put up a valiant fight,
the anomaly was able to destroy it by falling
onto it again and again until the golem was
no longer able to get back up.
There are few creatures that would survive
having a boat drop itself on top of them repeatedly,
and sadly the security golem was not one of
them.
With the golem out of the way, the boat continued
to drag itself through the streets wildly,
crashing through the side of a local restaurant
where its owner, an entity known as THE GRUEL,
was in the middle of a busy brunch service.
At the sight of the invading watercraft, THE
GRUEL set down his pitcher of bottomless mimosas,
wiped his hands on his apron, and grabbed
his trusty dual-wield swords from underneath
the counter.
He kept them there in case someone attempted
to dine and dash, but he figured they would
do just fine against a blood-drinking tugboat.
While THE GRUEL kept the tugboat busy, UIU
forces were able to break through the barricade
of boats for a brief period of time, allowing
more security golems to enter the area, as
well as allowing more citizens to escape.
Unfortunately, this little victory was short-lived
as further unforeseen horrors drudged themselves
up from the deep.
The reanimated corpses of various species
native to the harbor began to crawl out of
the water, surrounding THE GRUEL and allowing
the tugboat to escape the fight.
As it made its way back to the harbor, every
boat it passed attempted to toss bodies onto
the tugboat, covering it in fresh blood.
Slowly but surely, the damage to the tugboat
began to repair itself.
Once the boat had regained its strength, it
set its sights on a previously untouched cargo
ship.
An observing UIU officer determined that the
boat was somehow attempting to convert the
cargo ship, to transform it into another one
of its fleshy allies.
But before the transformation could take place,
a cargo crate broke open, spilling over 1,000
hardtack crackers.
Suddenly, the tugboat stopped everything that
it was doing.
It took one tendril, and began to count each
individual cracker that had spilled out.
While the tugboat was distracted with its
task, a citizen offered the UIU use of their
"rare metals cannonball collection" in the
fight to apprehend the aggressive boat.
One particular cannonball, made from electrum,
was able to puncture the hull of one of the
infected ships, rendering it motionless.
They were elated to have found a weapon that
worked against these boats!
While the tugboat continued to count, the
remaining townspeople gathered all of the
electrum they could find, and began to fight
back against the boats.
One by one, the boats sank, and all the while
the tugboat continued to count.
In the meantime, UIU officers managed to free
THE GRUEL from his zombie attackers.
They presented him with an electrum cannonball,
which he proceeded to punch finger holes into
and wield like a bowling ball.
Then, THE GRUEL had a score to settle.
No one, whether human, ghost, or tugboat,
was going to mess with his brunch.
THE GRUEL barreled toward the harbor, grabbed
hold of the still-distracted tugboat, and
punched it hard with his cannonball fist.
If the tugboat could breathe, the punch would
have knocked the air out of its lungs.
THE GRUEL then threw the tugboat out of the
water and continued the savage beating, before
preparing to destroy the battered vehicle
once and for all.
He lifted it up into the air, jumped up to
follow it, and hit it with so much force that
the tugboat careened through the air, colliding
with a portal that transported it to the Isle
of Portland.
Luckily, this particular portal could only
be unlocked via a high-speed impact from a
water-based vehicle.
Speaking of luck, an SCP Foundation team was
returning to the Isle from a failed mission
just as the anomalous boat appeared in their
reality.
The object was knocked unconscious by the
impact of its travel (and the beating from
THE GRUEL), and in its incapacitated state,
it was transported to a nearby Foundation
Site.
There, it was contained and given the designation
of SCP-6426.
Due to its anomalous traits including the
consumption of blood, a talent for hypnosis,
and a compulsive counting habit, it was also
given the nickname The Vampire Boat.
SCP-6426 is a Keter-class, sapient, hostile
entity that, in an inactive state, bears the
appearance of a harbor tugboat in a constant
state of rust and degradation.
Any blood (or organs containing blood) that
comes into contact with the boat will be absorbed
through the metal, causing the degradation
to visibly improve as a result.
The most effective blood appears to come from
humans, cetaceans, and a few specific species
of selachians.
The entity does not only use the absorbed
blood to improve its appearance, but is also
capable of using it to create organic additions
to its body, including the vein-like tendrils
spotted in the Three Portlands, cognitohazardous
eyes attached to bending eyestalks, harpoon
guns, and cannons capable of firing ammunition
made from anomalous species of barnacles.
These barnacles are capable of reanimating
dead tissue on contact, and SCP-6426 frequently
uses them to create instances of SCP-6426-C,
masses of reanimated tissue that the boat
uses to aid in its attacks or self-defense.
SCP-6426 uses its tendrils to grab prey and
drag them toward itself, but the tendrils
serve an additional purpose as well.
Each of the tendrils has a mouth on the tip,
similar in structure to that of the North
American Medicinal Leech.
When the tendril has made contact with its
prey, the mouth will then bite into the spinal
column of the creature, causing its brain
function to cease as its canines grow long
and hollow, hard scales form on their skin,
and their muscle mass and bone density increase.
Once they have been transformed in this way,
organisms taken by SCP-6426 are designated
SCP-6426-A. These instances are used to the
entity's advantage, helping it to extract
blood from victims at a distance as well as
providing an additional line of defense and
offense.
In the event that SCP-6426 encounters another
watercraft, it is able to use SCP-6426-A to
convert the vehicle into an instance of SCP-6426-B.
These converted boats are similar to SCP-6426,
and are able to function on their own.
However, they are unable to produce their
own eyestalks or cannons, unable to create
SCP-6426-A instances, and do not appear to
be as intelligent as their creator.
In the early days of its containment, the
exact nature of the anomaly's intelligence
was the subject of debate amongst the research
staff.
However, on one specific occasion, the Foundation
was able to establish a line of direct communication
with SCP-6426, and conduct the first (and
so far, the only) interview with the vampiric
tugboat.
The inciting incident occurred when the arrival
of the Foundation's latest hardtack shipment
was delayed, leaving the boat with nothing
to count and nothing to keep it occupied.
Freed from the bounds of counting, it managed
to escape and grab hold of several Foundation
staff members with its tendrils.
After chasing the boat through the site, guards
were able to corner it, prompting the boat
to absorb the bodies it had taken, and use
the organic material to produce a siren that
emitted the sound of a human voice.
It is through this siren that SCP-6426 responded
to interview questions, using the voice of
one of its victims.
Junior Researcher Sajad Williamson, in spite
of his protests, was selected to conduct the
interview.
His fellow staff members refused to take no
for an answer, and as the newest hire, the
unpleasant job fell on his shoulders.
Much to everyone's surprise, the anomaly began
the conversation rather politely, saying:
"I am…
SO sorry.
I thought you were those self-righteous lunatics
from the church.
I apologize profusely for any trouble I may
have caused, and I want to point out I fully
support your mission.
Yes… our first line of defense against the
undersea menace!
I am more than willing to punch sharks.
Selachians!
Yes, right.
Haha… how rude of me, yes."
Dr. Williamson's first question concerned
SCP-6426's apparent intended victim back in
Three-Portlands: Albert Izatt.
SCP-6426 responded:
"Albert?
His first name is really Albert?
Huh.
Well, what other relationship is there to
say besides "the hunter" and "the hunted."
Admiral Izatt is a ruthless man, known for
terrorizing and slaughtering people like me.
He was leading a search party of those barbaric
nautiphiles, intending to gut me like a seal."
"What do you mean by 'people like you'?"
Dr. Williamson inquired.
"Free thinkers, of course!
People who are unafraid to break from the
mold, to carve their own path in life instead
of following the predetermined route set by
that ignorant 'check valve.'
The church is built upon a foundation of lies;
no one's really a petty officer on this ship,
we're all just… cabin boys, stumbling around
in the dark as we follow the commands of an
off-hands C.O.B.
Heh heheh… if you want real power, real
freedom, all you have to do is listen for
the call of the beast.
Open the porthole, and he'll squeeze you right
through.
Heheheh…"
Dr. Williamson, feeling rather in over his
head, attempted to convince one of his colleagues
to take over.
When he refused, however, Dr. Williamson continued.
"Could you explicate your activities within
the harbor?
And- and how you arrived there."
"Well, after I got the boatswains off my trail,
I found a cave to hide in- I was forced to
hide in!
Yes.
Forced to hide deep into the cave, which turned
out to be a tunnel!
Surprising.
The tunnel led to some coastal community where
I took refuge; licking my wounds in the safety
of the depths as those zealots stalked the
surface.
I spent my time preparing, gathering the strength
necessary to face them once more.
Until I was ambushed, assaulted within my
hideout by a boatswain.
I fought for my life as I was forced out into
the open and descended upon by a manner of
monsters and freaks, all of this orchestrated
by that scumbag Izatt.
I was beaten within an inch of my life before…
hm.
I'm not quite sure what happened after that;
I believe I was knocked unconscious.
You'll have to illuminate me on how I came
to be in your custody."
At this point, the interview began to veer
in an odd direction.
The boat expressed confusion about the nature
of Williamson's questions, specifically how
little they related to the subject of sharks,
and punching them.
It was at this point that the Site Director
sought guidance from the Multi-U Department.
A researcher there informed Williamson about
the confusion.
SCP-6426 had mistaken the SCP Foundation for
another organization, the Shark Punching Center.
Dr. Williamson resumed the interview, prepared
to play along and keep the boat comfortable.
Unfortunately, Williamson was a terrible liar.
"Yes, we are the Shark Punching Centre.
We will determine if you are a suitable candidate
to carry out the mission: to search, punch,
and contain shar- I mean selachians."
This verbal misstep caused SCP-6426 to become
suspicious.
After a moment, it pieced together the truth
and began to throw itself against the wall
in a desperate attempt to escape.
It was apprehended by security guards, who
impaled it with a naval ram and returned the
watercraft to its containment cell.
The exact reason for its apparent fear and
hatred of the Foundation is currently unknown,
and the boat has made no attempt to speak
since.
Currently, SCP-6426 is kept in a 39m x 39m
x 50m containment chamber.
Beneath the chamber, there is an artificial
lava tube.
The tugboat has a navel ram through its hull
and engine, holding it in place.
This ram is checked daily for signs of degradation,
as it is the primary force keeping the anomaly
immobile.
If the ram is ever removed, or damaged somehow,
a failsafe system will activate, releasing
100 hardtack crackers and two pieces of electrum
into the containment chamber.
This is intended to keep the tugboat occupied
until the naval rod can be replaced.
If, for some reason, the naval rod fails and
the boat runs out of hardtack to count...well,
there will be nowhere, on water or land, that
we can hide.
Now go check out “SCP-1861 - The Crew of
the HMS Wintersheimer” and “SCP-4217 - Contain
The Bismarck.”